pourquoi ce déplacement ce soir cétait
important d'être ici fa pas la fête
ouais Philippe je vais vous couper
Baladur dans un instant parce que
Monsieur Édouard Baladur doit prendre la
parole d'un instant à l'autre voilà
monsieur baladour nous vous écoutons
c'est à vous les Français viennent
d'élire Monsieur Jacques Chirac
président de la
République je lui présente toutes mes
félicitations en mon nom comme au nom de
ceux qui m'ont soutenu et qui ainsi que
je le leur ai demandé ont voté pour lui
au second
tour il faut maintenant poursuivre
l'œuvre de redressement et de rée de
notre pays qui déjà a produit des
résultats visibles et pour cela
rassembler le plus grand nombre de
français dans un esprit de tolérance et
de respect mutuel je suis que le nouveau
président de la République s'y attachera
de toutes ses forces
je forme des vœux très sincères pour son
succès en le faisant j'en forme ainsi
pour la France voilà vous venez
d'entendre la réaction d'douard Baladur
à
l'électionende Monsieur bad Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous nous entendez